the claws are out Katy Perry seemingly  reacts to all the Taylor Swift Calvin  Harris drama flooding our feeds but  first let's recap  so it turns out that Calvin Harris and  Rihanna's summer hit this is what you  came for was written by Calvin's ex  Taylor Swift but the real drama began  Wednesday morning when Calvin slammed  Taylor and her team on Twitter saying  they're trying to make him look bad and  it's quote hurtful and that's where  Taylor's rumor nemesis comes in the DJ  producer tweeted Taylor quote needs  someone new to try and bury like keen  Katy's reaction this simple yet  effective gif of Hillary Clinton amazing  but then Katy took it to the next level  retweeting her own tweet from 2015 time  the ultimate truth teller  it's the clock back we came for  everybody's always wondering